let's take a moment now to pause and
remember philadelphia's first black tv
reporter her name is trudy haynes
what made you decide to take on a part
like this do i look like i should be at
the auto show right here in philadelphia
at the convention center
miss trudy as she was affectionately
known died yesterday she was 95 years
old haynes blazed the trail in
philadelphia as a reporter and anchor
for cbs station kyw where she worked for
more than 30 years interviewing everyone
guys from martin luther king jr there
she is with dr king to muhammad ali the
greatest
haines said she often faced racism and
sexism as she worked her way to the top
of the industry listen to this
it was challenging but it was a pleasant
challenge hey can you do this sure give
me a chance give me that opportunity or
i just go in and take it
to kyw alumni jericho duncan emery green
jericho told me she broke barriers if
not for her we wouldn't have even seen
the dream emery says she commanded
immense respect and ooze class and
intelligence she will be missed she said
it was a challenge but it was a pleasure
that's right about that she's a
trailblazer for sure